our good everybody welcome to the
corridor cast we got a lot of requests
from the audio-only crowd to state who
the heck is on the podcast before we get
too deep into it so for all you audio
listeners out there today we have
special guests Niko pairing er hi
we've got Wes was good Armstrong well
we've got Christian burger strim oh
hello hello
and of course Clinton the one and only
Kona sure Jones
that's me everybody and your host me
Jake Watson so Wes and I were
chit-chatting the other day just you
know kind of about life and about what
does it all mean and how do you prepare
for moments like a quarantine and what
do you learn during moments of a
quarantine and we came across the topic
of personal finance and so I'd like to
caveat this first and foremost this
whole conversation none of us here are
financial experts you guys all know that
we don't normally ask for financial
advice and we're not offering financial
advice here we're just telling our tales
but what we'd like to do in this podcast
is sort of give you a perspective on on
where each of us are at with our
personal finances what we learned how we
learned it how we came to learn those
things and hopefully that will give you
a little bit of a perspective on what
just some some other average Joes across
the across the stage or across the world
are doing for themselves and trying to
weather the storm of a quarantine and
things of that nature so welcome and I'm
glad everyone's here guys thanks for
joining yeah before here on our podcast
you know thanks for having me happy to
be here ready to learn share automation
so so with that said I mean I think the
first and foremost thing though that we
should kick it off with is just
weird at what point in your life did you
start to think about
hey finances maybe I should maybe I
should save them maybe I should squirrel
a little bit away what was your first
experience with with personal finance
and it can be a tale from when you were
a kid or it can be just as recently as
yesterday but I'd like to kind of kick
it off with that and see where that goes
I think yeah last week oh no I'm sorry
not last week top of the quarantine you
know just like what is it about
financing and money that I do not know
and so I started out with uh you know I
looked up a bunch of things I'm like
just finance in general like how to grow
your money and I came across rich data
for today and I listened to the
audiobook and I just haven't stopped so
like the past month I've been knee-deep
into everything finance so did it come
from the fact that you were sitting
there and you watched the Dow Jones
Industrial drop you three days okay
what's going on here I do just do
different conversations around you hear
people say oh yeah it's not markets down
yes I'm their best and I'm like what are
you guys talking about what does that
mean exactly is that and nobody was
really giving me information but I felt
stupid asking what does that mean so I
just went Google of like you know like
learn about stock market know like what
books but I read and a whole bunch of
books came up and I was like all right
here about Rich Dad Poor Dad out let me
I mean let me just go through this and
see what's up and it just kind of opened
my mind so much stuff that's going on
that I have no idea about in terms of
stocks in terms of how to manage money
in terms of how to like when you get
money in I don't pay yourself first but
then invest you know like just take 30
percent or investments in tithing and so
let's start with that first let's start
with that first question like yeah we
all saw what happened in March and the
Dow Jones Industrial you know it went
down from about it was almost about to
cross 30
and it went down to 19 that's just on
just googled literally Dow Jones and go
to five-year view he's got one those
little things that sticks out like the
white tape if I have my assistant look
back on the ticker and but so that's the
that's the first thing is like when
someone says hey it's March 20th the Dow
Jones has gone from almost thirty
thousand to twenty thousand it's a good
time to buy yeah what does that mean in
your opinion what it means it's so you
know when you start investing you also
need to start being aware of like what
currency is and how it works and so like
if you buy one stock for ten dollars and
there's your Dow Jones illustration if
you buy one stock for ten dollars and
then go to five years a couple days
later that one stock is now worth twenty
dollars you know it's important it might
come on you but you're holding onto this
this piece of property which is
basically a share of a company usually
but it can be you know some Goods it can
be like a barrel of oil that you own you
know etc but I think they it really just
had some money that's going into the
hands of other businesses for them to
work with much like how money goes into
banks hands for them to deal with giving
out loans and things like that but when
when the value changes it's really
actually kind of changing the value of
the dollar in a way the money that you
use to buy that thing so right when the
stock goes down right when when the
stock market goes down and all the
prices dip down if you happen to be
holding dollars you dollars have become
more valuable on the stocks value
relative to a dollar has gone down so
that's a good time to buy because
basically you can think about the fact
that that assuming that the stock will
go back up it's basically on a discount
your dollars are more valuable you can
put into the stock which is less
valuable but which historically is more
valuable and then that value goes up now
you have to be careful if you're buying
individual stocks companies are not
guaranteed to succeed that's why one of
things we'll be talking about here are
things like index funds which are
basically a risk management way to
approach stocks and bonds and things
like that where you can spread out your
dollar amongst lots of different
companies evenly and at the point you
basically at that point you're just
you're buying into the economy if you
think that the
economy is going to go down you should
not invest in the bag go down I mean
permanently go down forever and if that
does happen we have many other bigger
things to worry about than how much
retirement savings we have but
historically the American economy has
grown to the rate of about 7% every year
you know some years are down years some
years are huge up years like I think
last year was like 15% in terms of
growth so you know it all it all evens
out in the wash as they might stay so
the idea is that when you are doing
investing not in the day-trading sense
but you know the casual put some money
away for later save for retirement cents
you're kind of just betting on the
entire economy to continue going up and
ideally your money grows at a 7% rate
every year now the thing that catches a
lot of people that I surprised the fact
that inflation which goes without two
and a half to three percent every year
inflation is making your money less
valuable if your money is just sitting
in a savings account so if you put you
know you put 300 bucks into your account
to buy an xbox ten years ago well guess
what Xbox is now cost four hundred
dollars and the three hundred bucks are
worth less than they were you know 10
years ago so if you are saving money if
you don't want to lose money on the fact
that you're saving money you need to
make sure that that money is invested in
a in a spot where it's going to grow
faster than inflation and what you don't
do is expose yourself to a bunch of risk
in that process so yeah that's why
things are at a discount right now
that's so they people say you should buy
right now is because the stock market is
down but historically it's going to go
back up and also we can really pinpoint
why it's down it's the coronavirus it's
obvious why it's down now if there's
like huge economic impacts from that
that we don't know yet you know that's
the risk that you kind of take because
there's a risk of invest but you know
your dollars right now if you happen to
have liquid dollars they will they will
buy you more stock than they did you
know three months ago when everything
was at its peak what's that
which number you're not being very good
no tell us tell us for audio anyway - oh
you know it they're trying to update my
system
on this windows needs to update are you
talking about updated so hard number he
was saying was like the number like Dow
Jones like dad phone set twenty four
thousand seven thirty yeah yeah what
number Nico
T well actually here go ahead let's
let's answer the question what that
number is I don't know what that number
is only thirty there's only 30 stocks
and the Dow Jones and that's the average
so I it I don't know the actual
specifics of how they get that number
but I do know that it is some form of
average there's some sort of averaging
arithmetic based upon the 30 stocks that
are in that exchange that create that
value yeah also the S&P 500 the Russell
3000 NASA yeah you can basically look at
the Dow Jones Industrial Average as an
index fund in a way and you can actually
buy index funds that match the Dow Jones
Industrial Average yeah so that overall
is that number goes up and down so will
your money is invested in it the value
of the index is the sum of the price of
one share of stock for each component
company divided by a factor which
changes whenever one of the component
stocks has a stocks with what it sounds
like it's basically all the stocks added
together yeah yeah there's no hold on to
buy one stock of every company in the
Dow Jones Industrial Average that's how
much it would cost you just spent 25
grand
yeah so uh there's a lot of fancy words
being thrown around like Dow Jones
Industrial and index funds and what is
interest where does it well actually I'm
going to throw out there that if we
start getting into the nitty-gritty of
these things we're gonna get bogged down
sore not we're not professionals I think
we're gonna be better off just talking
about our experience with this and like
how we approach it which which thirst
you go to Nikko I'm a big proponent of
Vanguard so hey everybody listening to
this podcast
thinking about investing at the end of
the day you're probably going to want to
look at Vanguard as your go-to once you
kind of have your head wrapped around it
if you've just looking to get started
and do something simple something like
betterment which is what Clint and
Christian have just kicked off with is a
great way to start Vanguard is when
you're gonna want to get a little more
serious about it I mean like there's so
many options out there I mean I mess
around like a few different ones I did I
did Robin Hood and then I did Yahoo
Finance
we're like young finance gives you kind
of like live updates of what's going on
currently in the stock market during the
opening hours and then I just went over
to TD ameritrade and send everything for
my Robert head over there and only like
that one I like that one right now
because it has like education you can
literally take classes on there about
everything that's going on so if I
wanted about mutual funds or ETFs or
stocks and bonds
I can literally take a three-hour class
read it test me the person and just
continue going that's awesome but here's
the catch and like here's how people get
screwed this happened to a lot of people
with 401ks which led to them passing
laws over it so anything that's a fund
or it's a collection of things
somebody's managing the fund even if
it's not actively managed some company
still has to set it up and manage it and
they will charge you fees to do so
so Vanguard for example afford their
stock market index fund which is
literally just a composite of the stock
market it represents the overall stock
market it's a very simple thing to set
up you just look at the stock market and
you take an average of all the different
companies and you buy into that you know
there's not a lot of active managing
there that has a point zero four percent
fee to use so basically if you have a
dollar in there it's going to cost you
four cents now sorry I said that wrong
they'll cost you if you have $100 in
there it'll cost you forty cents that's
how much it'll cost you so it's a really
low fee however something like their
retirement fund which is set up in a
different way to be actively changed a
little bit each year that has a point
twenty five percent fee so if you have a
hundred dollars in the market for that
you're looking at two dollars man my
math is so bad one particular hundred
dollars be $1 wait 25 25 25 cents we're
sorry I yelled honest at 40 cents I
meant to say it's for supporters yeah
yeah so it's a four cent fee versus a 25
cent fee on $100 now what the catch is
if that fee is too high say let's say
the stock market are you the fun you
have averages a 5% gain every year but
the fees are 3% but that means that
you're only going to make two percent on
that fund every year because for all the
5% that you gain the company isn't going
to take 3% of that back and 2% you're
not going to be inflation you'll be
losing money so you have to be really
careful with all the funds that you're
picking out that they don't have really
high expense ratios because that really
adds up over time and if you're paying
more than say a point 1 to point 2
percent fee on something you're probably
paying to get to like the point fours
you're starting to get a little screwed
here
Vanguard is known for having really low
fees which is why I recommend it to
anybody
investing for years right this is just a
charge that they charge you to have the
money in their fund yep and I believe
it's per year I could be wrong it might
be for a month or some like that but it
averages out to be that percentage so
I'm looking here that betterment and
wealthfront both charge an annual fee of
0.25 percent like you're saying um if
you want someone on the phone an advisor
on the phone it's gonna be 0.4% now tell
me how to do this but the reason so
point to 5%
it's not that yeah it's not bad it's a
uh it's an odd it's like basically on
autopilot
it's an autopilot thing like you set it
up you set all your parameters you set
your goals you said how long you want it
to go you said how risky went to be said
the percentage of stocks versus bonds
and you know each account like you'll
have a savings account or you'll have an
investment account you can change the
percentages and all that stuff so it's
Auto and for me like I'm just getting
started so that this is this is what I
need is like just like a Auto kind of
thing to see how this works and then
maybe in the future go to a it was at
Vanguard Vanguard
and that's manual that's like a manual
like kind of take the training wheels
off kind of situation I think right
that's why if he doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be because Vanguard set
up to I mean you're right a little bit
clint better mints a little bit simpler
but Vanguard's really not that
complicated because if you just if you
just want to be simple and automatic you
can have vanguard automatically take
money like say once per month from an
account if you want and then you can
have it automatically put it into a fund
and if you don't want to think about it
all you do is you pick a retirement fund
for the year you are retired and that's
it it'll do all the risk management for
you it'll do all the balancing for you
is it'll be like okay so as if you're a
will the people yeah you're like which
is the same as betterment basically at
that point yeah okay you're gonna retire
in 30 years we'll give you a slightly
higher risk and then as time passes the
risk will go down and the base of the
amount of bonds and safer investments
will go up in that account you don't
have to do anything you don't think
about it you don't to research it you
just buy the retirement fund for the
year you wanna retire we call it a day
so annual fees she doesn't have any
annual fees the only fee they have is
like 75 okay see I see sixty-five cents
it has $5 full transfer fee $0 partial
transfer fee I mean you're like closing
so what's the fund that you own um no
it's just I'm just kinda trade
individual stocks is it not no this is
this is going for everything no fees for
non-transactional fees or mutual funds
it says number of non transactional fees
for mutual funds more than so those are
there's are fees per transaction that's
talking about there it's actually we're
talking about annual fees for having an
account correct if we're having not
having an account or had for owning a
fund so anybody who has an index fund is
going to charge you or mutual fund or
anything like that it's going to charge
you a fee because they do have to deal
with paperwork and managing it and that
kind of stuff so you should see a cost
either a cost ratio or
a fee for the specific funds that you
have because TD Ameritrade is just a
company just like Vanguard is just a
company there isn't a Vanguard fund
there's specific funds within Vanguard
that you would buy so like I have the
retirement fund for example and I also
have the total stock market index fund
which I put a little bit of money into
when the stock market went down because
I anticipated that I'd go back up so the
stock market fund fee itself is only
0.4% mm-hmm maybe chat when I was
looking at just you know I don't know
when I was comparing against this thing
called marriage equality but I just
wanna kind of see like what yeah yeah
you you need to know what actual funds
you own within TD Ameritrade for us to
look at these and those but the fee
thing is really important because it
catches you by surprise because things
like you know point 25% 0.1% that all
sounds really small but let's say like
once again let's say you're making 6% on
your investments well 3% of that is
inflation just to keep up with inflation
so in reality your actual investment
growth your actual money growth is only
the X you know if you have 6% but 3
percent is inflation and your actual
growth is only 3% and then let's say
you're paying a fee of 0.5% you know
that's cutting that's cutting into your
actual wealth by an entire six percent
you're giving away of all of your money
you are making the company fed you know
for the managing your money and that
that really adds up over time that
becomes a lot of money so you have to be
careful with those fees because what
seems like a small percentage does
become big as time yeah if you if you're
if they're taking a 4% fee like and you
even just like a point five percent for
your point four percent fee like I mean
that's like huge huge but it's still you
know for comparison like if you if they
say it's say it's 2 percent ooh which is
you know pretty normal and and but
you're only gaining 5 percent a year
then you're really only getting 3
percent net and then and then there's
interest or there's inflation right and
then so so you're yeah you're yeah so
yeah that's super important and I think
we should be
we kind of went everywhere I think let's
take it back let's talk about
fundamentals here let's talk about like
for starting out what are some of the
things you should be you have okay I'm
Joe I'm Joe investor I've got $100 I
don't know anything what do I do you
know where do I go where do I put it
like all right let's each take one turn
doing a one-minute piece of head lice
buy a share of my favorite company or
yeah yeah I would say research the
company that you're interested in you
know like there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of there's always he say
she say but like your research is
probably the best you know find out more
about the company because what I don't
put a hundred don't if you only have a
hundred dollars and you're investing for
the first time yeah put it into a single
stock exactly yes right
would it you know like okay that's
gambling that's rule number one family
rule number one all in one but like
research the company and just kind like
spread it out and just look and see what
it does
mmm what this hundred-dollar does with
you know get up in the morning when the
stock market opens and what notice how
like you know thought to me kind of
moves off of the motion I mean as soon
as you know I must says something like a
crisis when he has a breaking rule
number one one was don't invest if you
have $100 don't put it into a single
company oh yeah what's that I think you
just cuz you're focusing on redo the
research in this company that you like
oh yeah sorry
broad strokes like the big yeah you're
looking long-term you're like how do I
save for retirement 30 years from now 20
years from now like hurt by a fund first
is the first thing and do it to a
company that's safe and do it through a
company that's tried-and-true and do it
through a company that has low costs on
on the money that you're putting in so
let's go to go to people that are
do it with trillions of dollars try to
find one that has a low interest rate a
low take rate on the money that you give
them for that for that fund and and
start there you say mutual fund first
with a well rounded company yeah like
start start there get take take your if
you've got $100 and you're starting out
take 90 of them take 80 of them and
start there okay well first actually
I'll my turn okay go for it Niko okay
first things first you need an emergency
fund
so take like take your living costs take
three months of living costs that money
does not go into the stock market just
is not going to investments at all I
would take the money I would put it into
a lie there's a source online Bank
allied bank they have a savings account
it's one and a half to two percent so
your money at least you can put in there
it's at no risk it's not you know
subject to any stock since then yeah at
least grow up one and a half to two
percent so particular your emergency
fund put it in there everybody should
have an emergency fund we just
demonstrated in real life these paths
this past six weeks that everybody needs
an emergency fund because suddenly your
job disappears and you are out and
you're floundering and trying to figure
out where your next meal is going to
come from so you need to at least have
three months level living expenses saved
up in your emergency fund and like I
said put it in a lie account but it at
least get one and a half to two percent
cuz that adds up over time that's number
one right that's that's number one
that's like before you even invest how
low interest annually
Milly interest in Nellie account know
yet what wouldn't have two percent and
that fluctuates as the market fluctuates
but it never goes down you'll never lose
money in that account don't put your
money in a savings account at your bank
because they're gonna give you like
point zero one percent and they're gonna
catch you on fees and they're gonna use
you to make money you will not make
money through your bank your checking
account does not make you any money on
interest any money yep okay we can
basically guys the podcast just started
I know you
listening for 30 minutes it just started
this is real number one yep take three
to six months of your personal living
expenses and put it in a savings an
interest-bearing an interest-bearing
savings account yeah not a CD by the way
not a CD you can see that back if you
need it what a CD stand for by the way
if certificate of deposit no yeah some
like that I think it's like certified it
is a certificate of deposit account yeah
yeah I learned about my mom told me
about this it's basically money that you
don't want to touch once you put it in
there cuz it's only gonna make that
interest if you let it go within that
certain time period so it's probably not
your best option because the allottee
your terms
yeah you have to buy them on terms so
you can't really touch the money into
that terms up or else you forfeit like
all that interest and probably extra
fees yeah so what nico saying is like a
thing like a lie bank it's got a better
interest rate but you can access that
money when needed
yeah so I got some for you guys here no
those are very different a CD is
basically just a guaranteed return on
money so somebody says don't do it
though don't let CD you know that money
your grandkids don't know for your
grandkids give them an index if you're
trying to get money saved up for the
first time in your life first of all
control your spending that can take
three months of earnings and put it into
an interest-bearing savings account bank
account liquid cash hey start up stuff
to pay off any debts that are costing
you more than six percent
Oh God because that's a guaranteed six
percent return on your money the market
is not guaranteed on average it's six to
seven percent but is not guaranteed pay
off any debts that are charging you more
than six percent first before you put
any money into investing if you have
debts are charging you a like 3% or 4%
that's where you I might actually make
more money investing that money than
like paying off the debt so don't worry
about that quite as much you can pay off
the debt slowly but anything more than
five to six percent
get rid of that first all your I had a
law school one
it was 8.3% booth and I paid that off
first thing cuz I knew that I would
linger unless I had a guaranteed like
10% return on something there was no
better way to make money than to pay off
that loan yeah I think with my student
loan I got rid of my student loan first
nice and your and then your credit will
go up when you do that student soon debt
is tough I think that's one of the rule
number two yeah pay off I interest that
any high interest debt I don't know why
I'm writing this down I guess if you can
read that I could read that that's great
I'll be legible okay great all right
we're making progress here all right now
you're ready for investing you got your
emergency fund set up and you've got
anything that's costing you like more
than five to six percent paid off
hopefully now you're ready to start so
you got some more money gets more funds
now you're ready to start paying that
off all right next thing you do you can
start investing but and this is where
West's question comes in when we start
investing do it through an IRA first the
reason for that is because the
government taxes you on the money you
make and so everything you make you're
gonna get a little chip taken off of it
every time anytime this is like
dividends going out you can get somebody
taken away from the government any time
you want to sell it and like buy
something else you can get money taken
away from the government and capital
gains taxes are 20% so let's say you buy
a stock not to get dividends but just
you're gonna sell the stock down the
line you bought it for a hundred bucks
it increases to you know two hundred
dollars wow what a great investment well
the government's gonna come in and take
$20 that away so two percent of that
growth is gone from the government
taking it I think my math sprack there I
try to keep it to a hundred so is easy
so you have to keep in mind that you
know when you're just doing regular
invest
not IRA the government's going to take
its out of it and it's going to impact
your growth just like you know the
person managing the fund is going to get
fees that impacts your growth and the
whole idea is that you're only growing
at five to six to seven percent so you
really got to minimize these these
things that chip away at that so an IRA
is a is a tax sheltered investment
account and there's two flavors of it
there's a regular IRA there's a Roth IRA
I'll give a quick overview of them so a
regular IRA you put money into the
account without having to pay taxes on
it so like let's say you've made you
know a thousand dollars and you want to
put it into your IRA the government will
not charge you tax them that thousand
dollars because for every dollar that
you make you're really only making
seventy to eighty cents because the
government technically is you know
taking that next twenty to thirty
percent so this time you need to keep
all of your dollars 100 percent of your
dollar that you earn and you get to
invest that so right there you already
saving money and then in that IRA which
mean you can buy any stock you want can
buy any fund you want it's basically
just a categorization of that money it's
not an actual thing it's just a
categorization anything that you know
having that IRA it's to grow tax-free
you can buy and sell stocks within a
tax-free as long as you don't take the
money out then finally when it does
become time to take the money out and
here's the catch you can't take it out
until you are 60 years old once you do
take the money out you will pay it in
income tax on that money but only income
tax you don't have to pay your capital
gains or anything like that so that the
bet with an IRA is that you'll be you're
making more money right now and you will
be when you are retired and pulling
money out of it and if you are making
more money when you're retired well good
job your money there yep you're doing
great now for those of you guys who are
all the government's gonna raise taxes
big government etc you have something
called a Roth IRA in the Roth IRA is
basically the same thing you're tat your
money that's now invested in that IRA
gets to grow tax-free however you've
paid your income taxes up front so if
you made a thousand bucks you have to
pay the government the income taxes
first so you really only get to keep you
know semi eighty percent of that yep and
then you get to invest it and but when
you take it out you don't have to pay
income tax and you get that lump sum
that taught that full
a mouse yep no taxes on it at that point
so it's just less on the upfront that
you're depositing if you go with the
Roth because they take it out initially
or you wait until you're 60 and have a
big chunk of that taken out after the
fact exactly and honestly at the end of
the day it all comes out to be kind of
the same thing because you know one
you're starting with a smaller number
and then growing it tax-free the other
one is telling with the bigger number
and you're growing a taxi but you have
to take a chunk out at the end you know
so somewhere in the process I'm you're
holding that high rate for yeah yeah
Roth IRA income upfront when I can you
also think for stocks as well yeah you
can buy stocks through your IRA yep
these probably want to go a little risk
on that right like you probably want to
do more bonds than stocks you actually
know you'd want to go high risk on your
IRA unless you are old so that I thought
the high view behind the IRA is that the
government wants to encourage you to
save for your retirement so you can only
like it said you can pull money out
beforehand but there's a big penalty
generally speaking you can only pull
money out after when you are 60 years
old so that right now you know for me
that's 26 years away which is kind of
scary when I think about but for most
people here in this in this in this
group it's somewhere between you know 20
and 30 years away so that's a long time
if the stock market dips like it just
dipped last month it's not going to be a
big deal 20 years from now like that's
where the whole blob average comes into
play like hey the stock market averages
seven percent a year well over twenty to
thirty years you're probably good in
fact there's not you can't pick a point
in the stock market history or somebody
can buy money and then have lost money
if they've held it in the stock market
for that long period of time even if you
bought at the worst possible high and
you are selling it the worst possible
low twenty or thirty years later there's
no way to do that right now to actually
have that work out to have you lose
money because it's just the stock market
averages at seven percent over time so
you actually want to go a little bit
higher risk
for the longer time that you have in the
market if you're only gonna be in the
market for a couple years go really low
risk if you're gonna be in the market
for 30 years go high risk because that
time mitigates that risk a verge yep I
mean don't buy crappy stocks don't go
too hard on it you know be smart any
stocks and call it a day
yeah where they are a is they're like
they're like an option to kind of do it
in the same like index way where it
spreads it out or when you're doing IRA
here specifically choosing companies and
stocks you can you can buy literally the
exact same stocks index funds mutual
funds etc ETF's
you can do the exact same thing in an
IRA that you do in a regular brokerage
account it's literally just a
classification for that money to not get
it to Morris and it's more for
retirement and non-text yes the whole
idea is for retirement and you can
actually so you ready for some more
cashes there's a limit to how much you
can put into your IRA it's I think it's
now it's six thousand five hundred
dollars a year so you you can't put more
money than that into your IRA to save up
until you are 55 years old then you
could put more money into your IRA if
you wants it's just gonna sit there for
a few years
yeah so just just be aware of that yes
it depends on the stocks and the indexes
that you buy so yes and then when I
became like 90 like I'm still in college
but like I'm broken I might I need to
get my money out you know it's so like I
went and I withdrew it they're like it's
a high interest rate you wanted
withdrawn right now and I was like cool
I need it you just needed it gotcha you
know I mean so like that five came to
being like maybe like 4,200 or 3500
something like that but for me I was
like cool yeah it's a 10% penalty you
lost in early withdrawal you lost at ten
percent obviously you're young and you
needed the cash now gains interest
unattached and
stocks right there that still games yeah
we should be clarifying you're saying
interest technically that's not interest
you gain interest on like say a bank
account that's giving you interest when
you buy an index fund you're not gaining
interest you're gaining value in an
index fund it pays you in many different
ways there's others dividends hopefully
where if you own a stock in a company
every year they give you a percentage of
the profit there's the actual value of
the stock itself going up but that's not
interest that's just people tend to use
the word interest interchangeably
because we're used to interest just
referring to how much money you know
you're gaining over tiding on top yeah
yeah so just want to be clear on that
the dividends are off of a so remember
an index fund is just a collection of
stocks an index fund is just you know
one stock from Apple one stock from
Tesla one stock from its Facebook you
know anything any company you know like
Jake said there's farming index funds
that are you know food related now
there's different agriculture businesses
there's textile index funds there's
health company index funds there's the
entire stock market broad stock market
index funds and they are comprised of
shares of individual companies and
because it's a group of people buying
into it okay that's where the term
mutual fund comes from you know they can
rather than you having to be able to
afford an entire share of every company
you can just get a portion of a share
because somebody else owns the other
portion of a share so yeah it's so you
only get dividends if you happen to own
shares in a company that gives dividends
for their stocks um many of them do but
different companies are different some
companies try to have a very even stock
price and they have a just a decent
dividend payout at the end of the year
which is similar to say how a lie gives
you a one and a half to two percent on
your money that's in their bank account
at the end of the year other companies
don't give dividends and they just try
to have their stock value grow and then
you make your money and that company not
by not by the dividends but by selling
the stock after the value has ideally
gone up
cool well I'm gonna jump in here I know
we're jumping all over the place but I'm
kind of gonna dial it back for the more
layman's person listening or watching
yeah just kind of bringing us up where I
met so and also to kind of answer Jake's
opening question of like personal
finance and where we were I would say
you know as I got into my professional
career and after I kind of got past that
point of obviously I'm making enough to
live where I live and and you know
basically the cost of living there was
definitely a moment where I was like
okay now I see the value of like taking
some of that extra money that I'm making
and making sure I say that because it's
obviously a great idea to you know in
case anything goes wrong it's good to
have a little bit of a savings and now
so then yeah now we go like till today
or you know present time I feel like
I've done pretty good on the step
checklist that we just did that Jake
wrote out you know started building a
savings got rid of the kind of the Adept
and now I'm at the point where I'm like
starting to realize okay you know I've
got a grasp on my cost of living and how
to you know just save money on my own
now I want to get to a point and now
that I'm researching and learning laying
it with you guys in Clint like how do I
start investing to have my money make
money for me right and so that's kind of
where I'm at and so yeah where I'm
starting at is that I joined that that
betterment app and it was very you know
intuitive and super easy to think so I'm
basically at the point of where I've put
a little money into invest in an index
fund and I chose one like the SMP 500
right so it spreads it across the whole
thing between stocks and bonds you know
and then obviously it's a long-term
thing I started like yesterday so I'm
not gonna see profits right away but you
know it's it's a long-term thing we're
talking like you know in five ten thirty
years you want to look back at that
money that you're putting in to you know
grow grow for you so then you you can
you know you value value booth to you
later and that's kind of where I've
started at you know but then yeah
obviously the next things I do want to
look into
obviously there's all kinds of tools of
like how to buy a home or how to save it
for kids but yeah I definitely the next
step for me is that I want to look into
this RA slash retirement fund like it
would be nice to know that when I've
decided to stop working that I'm still
you know so that's kind of where I'm so
I'm like yeah I've got the the
fundamentals of those steps done and I'm
just now dabbling into how do I you know
where do I put my my kind of overflow
cache into places where it can start
making money for any overtime so that's
where I'm at another thing yeah right
now that's this is all super helpful I
think all the IRA talked they were just
talking about is definitely piqued my
interest cuz a retirement fund is
something that you know I think knit
Clint we were on set yesterday said
something like a stat like yeah like
when you start or even Nika might have
said it like when you start at 25 you
know that's kind of like the trajectory
of how like to set yourself up for a
good feature so I'm 28 now maybe a
little bit late to the game but like you
said there's no better time to start
than now yeah it's the best time to
invest was 10 years ago
the next best time to invest is right
now yeah even if this market is high
like don't put all your money into it at
once
yeah but over time just a little bit
every month even if it's hide don't
don't try to time the market when it
comes to long-term investing whether you
bought at a peak or a valley does not
matter 20 or 30 years down the line yeah
that's what I kind of feel like - yeah I
don't want to go you know again yeah I'm
on the Clint side of things where it's
like I don't want to be the guy that's
looking at every individual stock and
trying to play the market like that like
you know I wanted obviously I wanted to
know that it's going to a good cause but
I kind of wanted to like you said
invested in things that are more secure
in the long term whether or not it's low
or high right now our instinct yeah
the hardest challenge that a lot of
people go through is the emotional ups
and downs you know like the 2008 crash
or right now with the you know the
coronavirus crash I guess it wasn't
really a crash but it definitely went
down it's very I guess but it bounced
back pretty quick to be honest I was
like a dirt crash yeah so you know I
think I saw my investments my savings my
retirement savings go down by 25%
wouldn't happened you know it's a lot of
money that I was saving up just
but it's I also have to remind myself
that a lot of that value that I saw was
because I mean I started investing like
six years ago at the request of my wife
she's like Nico you should start doing
this and I started my first IRA so when
I when looking at in that regard it's
like I was still just back to where I
like had I not done anything like I
still I would have had the same amount
of money I had after the clock in the
middle of the crash they were supporting
the crash
so like knowing that but like even you
know I was really just losing my gains I
hadn't lost anything like my actual
amount of the initial investment yeah
yeah because I you know that's six years
ago when the market was already at that
level or below it actually but the thing
is like that really tests your emotions
when you see that money like all that
value go down and you just have to
remember it's a long haul thing just let
it ride it'll come back up and if it
doesn't it means the world is [ __ ] and
you're just in trouble don't worry about
your retirement savings anymore you're
not gonna retire dollars aren't gonna be
worth anything anymore like you know how
much one you have does not matter so you
know that's that's the thought process
to shoot has so you let me see it all go
down just like just let it ride I mean
right now the markets already back from
the point where it was in like November
of last year so I back up - yeah it's
crazy it's that's how fast it bounced
back up you know and it's not always
gonna be like that but it's uh you just
gotta you gotta taking emotions out of
it you gotta put it in there and just
back I'm not gonna worry about it I'm
gonna let ride it might go down it might
go up just yeah I'm not talking an you
arey of last year yeah yeah you take the
money that you earn and then reinvest it
yes I do when when I have so like for
example let's say you have an investment
for your in your IRA and you have let's
just say you happen to buy an Apple
stock right you just you didn't do it
fun you just ripped just bought one one
share of Apple and let's say Apple pays
you a dividend you can decide to
reinvest that dividend back into another
stock or so for example let's say you
own a thousand dollars in an index fund
and the different things in there pay
dividends you can have it just buy more
of that index fund if you want or you
can have it you know go out and sit in
cash for you
do something with later if you want to
but I have all of my stuff that's in
long-term savings just automatically
reinvesting the dividends and that's
that's the regular IRA correct that's
you can do that through anything any any
index fund you'll have the option to
reinvest if it ends so question are you
currently still putting money into all
of these funds or are you at the point
where you're just reinvesting dividends
I still put a little bit money into all
these funds to focus on any specific one
that we yeah the positive or the general
investments or anything yep so this this
year is a little weird so I'm buying a
house so I'm not saving and not putting
any money into funds I'm putting the
money into a house but when the stock
market went down with the corona virus
epidemic I did put a little bit of money
into Vanguard's total stock market index
fund so the total stock market was down
it was suppressed I didn't want it to
research individual stocks so I just put
a little bit of money into that
anticipating like hey you know maybe it
goes up in a cup yeah you know maybe I
can make 10 percent of the money which
isn't huge at the end of the day but you
know if it takes you a minute in the
evening just like do a little transfer
and then you know a few months later in
the summer is like hey I made a hundred
bucks or whatever you know it's like you
know you made hundred bucks for a few
minutes now is that through your regular
Vanguard account or is that through one
of the IRA vehicles that's true Vanguard
I wasn't putting into an IRA but you can
like once again it's important
remembered that the IRA is not anything
really special it's just a category like
if you're on Vanguard you'll see like
your brokerage account you see as you
can select different vehicles within
yeah it's yeah it's just like a coat for
your money but exactly tells the
government when you want to be taxed on
it yep that's all it is
so you can buy the exact same stocks
index funds etc in an IRA that you can
in a regular brokerage account I'm gonna
dipped you put some money into the index
fund of just the overall stock market
would you be comparable to the S&P 500
but you're talking about yeah yeah it's
basically you know vanguard of exchange
yep so the two funds that I put most of
my money into is the target retirement
fund
and the total stock market index fund um
the stock market index fund is the risky
one that's the one that is just pure
stocks the stock when it goes down it
goes down so like if I for example
saving up for my down payment I didn't
put that into the total stock market
index fund because there's no guarantee
that that would be that's gonna where I
needed a yeah I didn't actually I didn't
even put that into my target retirement
fund I mean I put a little bit in there
but most I just went into a lie and sat
in a lie because I didn't want I didn't
want to have the risk exposure and you
know I I started saving for downpayment
like about five years ago and there's no
guarantee that you're gonna make money
on in a five-year span that's actually a
pretty short time span when it comes to
long term investing so that's why I went
with a really safe route but yeah if
people are like looking at to get into
this I would recommend starting with the
total stock or so I'd recommend starting
with the retirement fund um like I have
a target retirement 2055 fund for
example and then if you're feeling a
little risky and a little frisky I could
put a little bit more money into yeah
then you can put a little bit more into
the total stock market index fund and
that one I try time it a little bit
sometimes like if I see it that it dips
down like I've been waiting to put some
money into it I'll do it then but it
doesn't really matter at the end of the
day so yeah those are those are those
are the types of vehicles that that that
when you actually start putting dollars
in through an investment whether that's
through an IRA or just through like a
vanguard or a Transamerica account or
what-have-you
you're talking about like broad-strokes
vehicles yep you know one that indexes
entire stock markets another that's a
mutual fund another that's you know
something that's gonna be a low risk
long term yeah whether it's high risk
now and it's like a through an IRA and
it gets more low risk over time or
what-have-you but that's that's where
you want to start is like so now you're
talking about like three to six months
of your savings of your personal like
cost-of-living right is now that's an
interest-bearing savings account
and then wave what's rule number two
guys we've got high interest debt you've
paid off your high end for that right
and now got your vehicles so that's now
after that that's when you can start
that's when I at least at that point
that's when I started thinking about
like hey what are some blue chip stocks
that I can do how's this know I wonder
if I can buy this one and and what will
happen if I give them one if I buy one
chair yep
and that's yeah only once you have
everything else kind of covered is it
time to start doing that and that's like
for example I'm pretty confident that
Google's gonna continue to make money
and so I buy like one google share you
know I'm pretty confident that Amazon's
on the path to continue growing this
business I bought one Amazon chair like
you know if you're in an industry and
you're very close to how the economics
are working in part of the industry feel
free to rely on your knowledge that
industry and buy a couple shares my
Dobby stocks to twenties on what's it at
now 350 Wow so yeah if you're you know
if you're close yeah but I wouldn't just
go willy-nilly buying things yeah I
think this company's gonna be good so
you might be thinking yourself
alright cool like 6% 7% wait I have to
if I actually vest like 10 grand just
make 700 bucks like that's so much money
to like just make a little bit back so
you might be think like looking at the
percentages in thinking that and here's
here's the thing here's the trick so at
a 7% gain each year your money will
double every ten years
so as you're 25 and you put 5,000
dollars into an IRA and you didn't do
anything else until you're 65 you
literally didn't save a single penny
well from 25 to 35 hmm 10 grand from 35
to 45 is gonna become 20 from 45 to 55 s
can come for tea and that's what that
1565 there nothin it becomes a tea so
that $5,000 becomes eighty thousand
dollars by the time you retire just
sitting there so if you are every year
putting it you know a thousand dollars
into
retirement or a couple little bit more
as you can that really adds up and if
you think about it you know people are
living longer you know if you retire at
65 you probably make it until your
eighties at least but you know that's
true but still it goes to show you
that's a that's a full year of high
living when you're 65 for five grand
when you're 25 yeah yep
so you can keep doing a little bit that
every year it will really add up and
you'll be able to have some money when
you get old microphone is saying can you
say that again you say 7% gain each year
you'll double it every ten years correct
yes seven and a half yeah ten years
you're saying are a retirement fund any
any venting anything any any if I own a
single share of Apple and and for the
next 40 years apples share price goes up
7.5% this is just simple math so any any
average that you can garner anywhere in
any investment if you can average seven
and a half percent you're you're doing
great yeah it means their money will
double every ten years in the stock
market remember historically averages
around six to seven percent so it's
totally feasible to actually actually
have this work for you like historically
it works so yeah do not be discouraged
all right so say and it jumps you know
by the end of the week to 700 bucks
four five six four two bucks profit
right and then one that one share that
one chair and I want to take that for
two bucks and I went to draw it out and
four dollars on I wouldn't do yeah I
would I could either move that stock
someplace else or didn't use that cash
to drop it in my account or by other
sucks correct yes but you will have to
of course sell that Apple share to
realize that game so you need to pay a
brokerage fee to sell that share
depending on which service you're using
which can be anywhere from like $1 to $5
and then you'll also if you don't
reinvest it or its profit at the end of
the year you'll need to pay capital
gains tax on it unless it's in an IRA
yeah you can't just use that 400 and
could take it somewhere else without
actually giving up that one Apple star
Apple stock yeah and you'd have to pay
Uncle Sam is 20% cap yeah so every time
I pull out and say hey you know this is
more my buying power now that I that
I've earned I want to put it in as like
buying power that capital gains on it
yes at the end of the year yes at the
end of the year whichever whichever
institution you use to do your trading
will send you a tax form that says how
much you made or lost that year which
will be taxed at capital games yep and
any part of this is because they
actually don't want you to be constantly
buying something yeah yeah they're
weighted is there a way to do that
without pulling it all the way out to be
taxed if you're planning to just
reinvest it right away anyway or not cuz
well here's the thing here's I have to
think about it
you only get taxed when you make money
right you're not gonna text if you lose
money so let's say you started the year
100 bucks
you bought a stock accrue to 200 bucks
you sold that stock and I have 200 bucks
to play with you bought another stock it
goes to 400 bucks you sell that now you
have foreigner bucks to play with and
then you know etc etc and then at the
end the year now you have $1,000 well
made $900 that's you know that's income
the government's going to charge you
capital gains or you know and other
types of taxes on that money but if at
the end of the year you've made a bad
decision also then you lost it all on
your back to 100 you don't owe them
anything you'll just pay them because
the losses will offset your games so you
have to only make money too you have to
pay capital gains but you will have to
pay capital gains anytime you have to
sold something and made money even if
you buy more stocks yeah I was gonna say
so even if I put that nine hundred
profit back into stock I'm still paying
taxes on that dozen so I still have to
have that money to pay even though I'm
using it to keep playing you're not
you're not a lot of people by surprise
at Bitcoin you're not going to Apple and
being like hey Apple hey guys can I buy
one of your stocks please you're doing
it through a brokerage firm
yeah and the brokerage firm will will
issue you a balance at the end of every
year that shows whether you gained or
lost it would be like here's where you
started here's where you ended so
because of that this is how much you are
the government there are they're always
like a P&L printout only if you sold
only if you sold yeah oh you're just
holding it that's these have to be
realized X form it's a basic tax form
but every brokerage entity that you use
to buy and sell any kind of vehicle
whether it's an individual stock or a
fund will allow you to take any money
you've earned and put it back into
something you know it's not like you
need to take it out put it in to put it
in things and get back out of your bank
account then put it into a new stock
like they'll save you that stuff so
you're just saying as long as you don't
actually make it into cash first and he
just free applying those funds to other
options then you're not gonna get tax
until you make it cash which you've had
and then you have take that give what
you will at some point today I'm
planning on it at some point you're
gonna want that cash and then it's gonna
be taxed yep yeah a lot of people got
caught by surprise with capital gains
taxes and bitcoins ever is like oh I got
I held onto some bitcoins and now
they're worth like a thousand dollars
they're worth $10,000 each I'm gonna
sell my
three bitcoins I'd made $30,000 in the
government's like you owe us ten grand
30k I used all and a lot of people like
I have 30k now I'm gonna buy more
bitcoins 30k I went down [ __ ] but then
what happens is like it went up in like
say 2018 and they bought all those
bitcoins in 2019 and then lost all their
money yeah but think I was like you
can't you can't carry over and do that
kind of stuff but you have to wait to do
so as well and you know everything I've
started out with is just small money all
the stocks I've done is just kinda like
individual let me just see what it does
not really big money and I finally was
like you know what I'm gonna put more
money into like crypto so I went and but
coins and today I noticed I gained 600
bucks all right money I already invested
so well you its unrealized gains just be
technically though that's unrealized
gains why is it and realized gains
because we actually haven't made that
money you have any of them the value is
higher but until you sell it you know
you might have that yeah you don't have
the problems until you've actually sold
it all right the profits until you sold
it okay so I still at the end of they
say say suddenly it's going to kind of
go back to like when it is it gonna go
off the because of the value changes you
know this is for our like thing the
value changes some some days it's low
some days high but when it's high that's
when I would sell so it's when it's high
or when I initially invest it I think
it's guys actually off of what you
deposit what you sell out like so if you
say you said you'd invest at six hundred
and you're selling it at nine hundred
you're gonna get nine hundred bucks in
the bank that has to be taxed correction
300 bucks 300 so just the game just the
games yeah just the gauges okay as your
six hundred that you already put in was
taxed when you earned it
gotcha okay
gonna be taxed when you take it out cuz
I see there's a there's I'm going to
coin basis I was like I believe on on
the eggs of your coin so it could go up
to like $2.99 or
per dollar I believe well that's that's
a coin basis fee on this coin base just
charging you for doing business with
them that's the capital gains that's
what the government's gonna take for the
capital gains but the capital gains is
only on the difference between the money
you put in and the money you take out
money you took out at the end of the day
when you sell it it's higher than the
money you put in it's that difference
not the entirety yeah so in West the
situation Uncle Sam would be taxing him
on that 300 but then coin base is also
taking 1% of either that whole thing or
even still the difference so yeah so say
you bought in at your six you're selling
at nine Uncle Sam's taxing 300 plus coin
basis taxing nine hundred one percent of
nine hundred for their feet just a man
what they did for you yep from the ear
date it'll be in that tax season right
so if you took out there's no it'll be
it'll be the entirety it doesn't matter
when you what the year it is like it's
just what you the difference between
when you bought it and when you sold it
whether it's within one year within ten
years it's just that it's all it matters
the difference between what you bought
it for and what you sold it for but
you'll be I'm just saying you pay that
tax on that year's taxes right because
that's money that's when you took out
some money yeah if you took that 900 out
today on your 2020 taxes you'd have to
get you'd get taxed on that 300 yeah but
let's say you also sold another stock
that I'd lost $300 this year at the end
of the year it would show a zero dollar
difference because you lost three
hundred dollars here and you gained
three hundred dollars here meaning that
your net was zero so you don't really
want to take something out and yeah it's
made fifteen to twenty percent more than
what used where you started that yep is
the message here well this is why this
is the this is the long haul this isn't
just like you then you just go
this is a hop in and try to get your
money back in a month and try to make a
little cash it's like this is like
you're really planning for your future
that's what I was doing at first I was
like oh no let me just sell this I was
like what the first day I got into this
I was watching the shake thing I done at
sundown I'm looking at his stock market
for hours after hours and I was like
this is not any way to live because I'm
going no way to live
yeah I think I think that I think that
crosses over into like where it's more
like gambling yeah I'm talking about
it's like you're trying to play the
specific stocks and you're hoping to get
the right hit on if you have every other
base covered and you're like yeah yeah
there's just there's 300 bucks what's
what the hell if it's just your [ __ ] you
money than yeah of course and then yeah
with it but that's what you want be
doing with your long o future goals this
is the Vegas fund where you already
planning to lose this when you're at the
tables in Vegas and if you happen to
walk away winner grids for you but you
were always planning altering that let
me apologize the money it's gone that's
you deep in the stock market but if you
give me more of yours yeah yeah the rest
of my family for the eighth time that's
not the conversation about rehabbing you
know I think one of the good rule of
thumb to when it comes to investing is
if you're going to invest in something
that's not an broad index fund ask
yourself
like for example cryptocurrency do you
think even if you're doing a short term
that's one thing and honestly
cryptocurrency is a short term game the
long term do you think that
cryptocurrency is going to be more
reliable increase in value more than the
entire American economy over the next
decade who's gonna win the American
economy a crypto order some people would
say crypto currency so don't you know
I'm not saying this yea but yeah i'll
take my 7%
of the stock market I'm I'm kind of I'm
playing oh right now I feel like they're
both important because it just seems
like the value of the dollar it's just
becoming less and less like if they're
printing out trillions of dollars or
kind of what did I worried the trillions
of dollars coming from doesn't that is
that mean so you actually have a good
thing with like printing quote-unquote
printing money mm-hmm so when people say
printing money it's it's you know it's a
real term because the government doesn't
actually just print more money the way
you so printing money means bringing
more money into the or increasing the
amount of money in circulation or
putting more money into you know the
money supply that actually happens
through loans um so each bank is
required to maintain a certain amount of
money within the bank if you guys
remember back in like the Great
Depression people would had runs on the
bank were like oh [ __ ] all my savings in
the bank I want my money right now and
the things like well we just had to give
that guy back his saving that guy back
here savings and we actually don't have
any more money for the money that we owe
you
what's that I believe it's 10% of all
they have out in loans they need to have
10% in actual actual cash as required by
the Federal Reserve Bank yeah so right
now you know Wes let's say that you have
$10,000 in the bank right
and let's say that I also have $10,000
in the bank and Clint has $10,000 in
Krishnas $10,000 and Jake is $10,000 in
the bank well if we all went to the bank
right now and all wanted our money back
they wouldn't have enough money to give
all of us because they're taking that
money and they're giving out to people
in real people here's $50,000 see you
and you'll pay us back this percentage
of a year here's $10,000 whew and we
have to keep the rest here on the bank
just to be safe so they said go ahead
and as I say but perceptually we all
still feel like we all individually have
$10,000 right like I have $10,000 in the
bank and you have $10,000 in the bank
but now there's another dude walking
around with a $50,000 loan so somehow
the money supply just went up we all
have $10,000 in the bank and there's
also now a guy with $50,000 so that's
how that's how intelligent reserve
system works that's how it's added or
printed for every US I have more money
gets burned every ten dollars
effectively that that you have an actual
cash there's another $90 out in loans
somewhere in somewhere in the economy
that are expected to be paid back to
support that actual $10 amount which is
why the the economy is so much larger in
a credit reserve system than it could be
so people always say like end the Fed
and you know there's always that
rhetoric that goes around but actually
what the Federal Reserve Bank allows to
happen is that exact process it allows
ten dollars to become $90 instead of it
just being ten dollars that's how you
print money but it but there is a
requirement that each bank needs to have
certain amounts in actual cash and then
also the the when there are spikes and
and there are depressions in the economy
the Federal Reserve can step in and say
hey we're gonna give out a loan to all
of these different financial
institutions to then take that and to do
with it what they think is best in terms
of like hey where's a safe investment
right now should we give it to people
that are trying to buy houses should we
give it to people that are investing
should we give it to new businesses what
should we do with it and then the bank
tries to determine where the safest the
best place is to get their money back is
because eventually they need to turn
around and pay the Fed back and then the
Fed after they get that money back they
then take down the federal bat so that
is and that's exactly what happened with
the Troubled Asset Relief Program back
in 2007-2008 and now if our government
could stop spending money that's a
different conversation but that is you
know all of that goes in to make up what
is known as like the federal the
national debt a lot of information this
is a lot of information so you could
people have studied volumes on this and
then I mean we're barely even getting
definitions right guy
I mean people do this is a full-time job
they're still learning things
yeah yeah I think this is a good first
lesson name of the day target soccer all
right stock market index fund or
Vanguard retirement fund those are my
recommendations if you're gonna start
with there's one catch Vanguard has a
$1,000 minimum to start with the fund
you have to save up at that point but if
you're saving up side points like
betterment is a great start before you
do any of that first aid your emergency
fund
wait they said Oh merged if I don't pay
your debt first emergency emergency fund
honestly like you don't want to burn
yourself kind of pay off a loan and then
have a cleansing have saving yeah I
would put in an emergency fund before
everything and and if you're listening
to this and you're thinking I don't need
an emergency fund
it's like like 20 million people just
realized they needed an emergency fund
did the twelve hundred bucks you got
make up for the high interest debt and
then spread out index retirement Iraq
sheltered tax sheltered national tax
sheltered it's whether you want to pay
taxes up front or when you deposit it
later and if you have a 401 K through
your work that's also a tax record fund
fees are higher on a 401 K
they are like cousin IRA doesn't have
fees outside of whatever funds you buy
if there's fees with those but a 401 K
does have a management fees however most
employers also offer a match so if you
say put $1,000 into your a a lot oil
that that's free money put it corporate
just force we just force all these
things like I'm gonna get a mutual fund
we're gonna index fund I want to get a
Vanguard
and I would have Roth IRA is that is
that smart hat make sure you have those
things that I covered all your bases or
is it you should pick one of the other
or is it overkill its well first off the
nayara is not different an IRA and a
mutual fund or not the same thing
remember the IRA is just a
classification it's just like Jake said
it's a coat that's some money where's to
say hey don't tax me so an index fund
can be the exact same index fund in and
outside of an IRA an IRA is just a
classification that says this money
doesn't get taxed on its growth but also
better to save for later life like
retirement right because yes so if
you're sitting boy you really don't put
it in an IRA because it's gonna be feed
fees or interest if you try to take out
too early
if you think IRA 401k just think
retirement yeah so are the other
investments are potentially stuff you
can use if things blow up now you want
to use that money but IRA you should be
playing that's you're planning for the
long-term retirement yeah yes so you
can't you can pull $10,000 out of an IRA
for a down payment on a house without
any penalty up to ten thousand is what
you're saying you could just pull up to
ten thousand without a without an issue
if you're the guy in Josh Hank
redemption right yeah the other day the
government wants you to safe retirement
they want you to buy a house they want
you to be stable and there's a lot of
like you know things like this but
ignore that ignore that ignores that if
it's going into your IRA you don't touch
it to your sixty just think of it that
way that's just how you should look at
it with sucks to me is like say you get
paid to like Pay Pal there's associated
with that money and then put it in you
know you're gonna take into whatever
like say something you're still going to
be taxed again of capital gains it's
just like I feel like there's like
you're full $2 not welcome to taxes
America and Wes let's just just became a
little bit of a Republican just right
there and it's like yeah you think about
what we do you and you know it's like
you got say say it's like you take a you
take a brand integration okay well the
brand goes to the agency says you have
the real dollars there's a it's a
thousand dollars and the brands like I
want to spend a thousand dollars on
marketing
I made this thousand dollars from
selling a product to a consumer so then
they turn back around and they already
got taxed on it all the way through
right and they got taxed on the storage
fee and they got taxed on the
distributor and they got taxed on the
retail they got taxed on the gains and
they can attacks on the corporate tax
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba and then they're finally
over thousand okay I've got okay what do
I do hit there like quick quick give it
to an influencer okay and then the
influencers like okay but don't be left
the agency without the aid directly to
them to an agency and it's like okay
okay we'll take your money we're gonna
take X amount of fee okay but then but
then we don't actually know the
influencers okay so you got to go to the
go to the MCN okay so then yeah okay
well we're gonna take this much and then
the N stands like okay cool
all right we got this vertical right
here you guys are gonna sell so many
pieces of toy you guys gonna sell so
much toilet paper you don't even know
you didn't want to know all this money
back like you're like okay and they're
starting across the agency and while the
agency's counting his money and then the
MC is like okay guys here here guys come
on over to possess somebody we're gonna
give it out and then in the end them
influencers are like oh hey hey but then
was like hey this guy here oh and then I
guess I made some money oh I got
operational costs for my channel
oh I better pay tax on that and then
I'll turn around and then and then you
turn around and you're like okay okay
how much do we make how much did they
make you're like that's is that less
than what they get wait what am where
where am i I'm /
turn around and you're like okay now do
i io tax okay now I owe I owe California
tax okay okay now I had to buy that car
okay now dude and it just goes on man it
just goes that thousand and you you end
up with like two and you're like I'm
just hoping for my seven and a half
percent
somebody please I love that [ __ ]
is it okay is it tax evasion if I'm like
say I'm working tally right tax but I'm
like you know what can we move to Iowa
worth like fifteen thanks nah no it
depends on like a safai that over
California is not done they're gonna ask
you they're gonna say how much of your
business enterprises were reliant on our
stage and then they're gonna say was it
X percent or was it X percent and you're
gonna have to give them an answer look
into it see you like okay maybe it's
this percent and then they're like hmm
all right we'll deal with that now but
I'll have the same conversation what's
this
look this is saying there's two things
in life they're inevitable death and
taxes and that's not a lie
you will pay taxes that's a lie one day
because everything has a cost that's why
because everything has a cost everything
has a cost and that's just how that's
how it is in ours that's how it is in
our economy that's how it is in nature
that's how it is at every level
everything has is equal and opposite
reaction and and at the end of the day
you know you just you just got to try to
make the process for someone to
eventually get those two bucks at the
end of the rainbow and make it as at
least as easy as you possibly can so
that they can then turn around and and
do that again and the more times that
that process repeats itself more
revolutions that there are the more
wealth is created for for everyone
when you when you create a when you
create like a mutual fund can you take
the individual stocks that you've
already bought and put it inside of
there no you'll have to sell them first
and then buy that mutual thing I think
Jake's a little like you all right there
was a great thank you for being our
everyman great thank you for inspiring
this conversation
Clint ended up just not talking part
ways and you were the inspiration yeah
well I guess that's good I guess
glad yeah right you know just like how
I'm gonna restructure everything that I
thought I was doing right you know those
new four steps to follow always that was
a learning curve it's always a process
and yeah like you told me the other day
every time I've ever lost money it was
because I thought that what I didn't
know what didn't matter yeah super
important and I've been I've been taking
that to heart as well so people helping
people reddit.com slash are slash
personal finance I give them a good
shout-out for helping you establish
basic investing techniques I'll text it
to you sometime sometime with our slash
personal finance just type that into
Google or reddit personal finance all
right fellas everybody thanks for
listening so much I appreciate it I was
good chatting with you dudes I'm really
into investments and actually talking
about them so this was uh this was a
joyous podcast for me yeah let us know
in the comments if you want to see more
and consider subscribing everybody